c'est une première pour les pompiers de
magny-les-hameaux neuf d'entre eux se
sont rendus ce mardi 9 avril sur le site
du distributeur électrique est né dis
salut en cours dans le cadre d'un
partenariat
ils ont découvert à cette occasion un
poste source un grand transformateur qui
permet d'abaisser la tension électrique
objectif créer une coopération pour la
prévention des risques pour leur
expliquer le chemin de l'électricité à
quel moment et ben on peut être amené à
intervenir nous pour couper
l'électricité si jamais il ya un risque
important sur une zone et de quelle
façon les pompiers pourront intervenir
avec notre appui en cas d'incident
pendant la visite les visages sont
concentrés les responsables des dix sont
présentés pendant toute la matinée les
différents secteurs de ce site qui
dessert l'électricité dans la zone de
saint quentin en yvelines et de
versailles
c'est une certaine norme aimant donc
déjà de voir concrètement le site son
fonctionnement et après d'avoir un
échange avec les acteurs on va dire un
échange physique avec avec les acteurs
et ça c'est toujours très intéressant
c'est un vrai plus et c'est toujours
mieux quand on comprend bien les choses
voilà et sur les interventions ça peut
nous aider également ce type de visite
est organisée une à deux fois dans
l'année dans le cadre d'un partenariat
renouvelé tous les trois ans
je voulais